from this day forth you put your faith
in me the harry potter actors had more
than just voldemort to worry about
during their time on set
for 11 years the wizarding universe
filled our world with magic and wonder
but for a lot of the cast it was the
darkest decade of their lives
it was dark times very dark times bonnie
wright took on the role of ginny weasley
when she was only just nine years old
and although she says she remembers her
time on the franchise very clearly
not all of it is positive she never
exactly had trouble getting along with
others on set
but she did struggle with the attention
she was getting outside of filming
she had a hard time trying to deal with
the spotlight and puberty at the same
time
given everything's going on maybe that's
the best reason to have it
she's been pretty open about what she
went through and said it's not fun when
you're a teenager experiencing those
things
you're growing into yourself and see
photos of yourself like oh god
who could blame her it couldn't have
been easy trying to live up to the
expectations people had for the
on-screen girlfriend of harry potter
either
bonnie's just glad she didn't have
social media at that point to torment
her further
i think as we've grown up with them all
we've realised this is actually very
unique and strange
it may be hard to believe but there was
a very long period of time where rupert
grint never really wanted to pursue
acting seriously
when i started acting was never
something that i aspired to do
i felt like i'd missed out on a lot
shocking
we know but that also meant he wasn't
prepared for the lifelong fame train
he'll likely be riding for the rest of
his life
or the years of his childhood he felt
were taken away because of all the time
he spent bringing ron weasley to the
screen
he eventually grew into his fame but
said it's like having a split
personality and even called his
experience
dehumanizing the feelings continued even
after the franchise was over
after we finished it was i felt a bit
lost really because it was it was such a
huge part of my life
because he had no idea how to live
without harry potter in his life
we've come to learn that emma watson is
a real-life hermione granger
which is epic but it also caused a lot
of problems as the actress grew up on
the camera
her set struggles literally started
during the philosopher's stone
this was her first ever role and she had
a habit of mouthing her co-stars lines
while they were filming
it's leviosa not
it might seem cute to us but for emma it
was traumatizing
oh i'm so sorry i'm so sorry oh
i feel so bad apart from ruining a few
takes in the beginning
like rupert and bonnie she really
struggled with the fame to the point
where she
didn't connect with the person who was
looking back at her in the mirror
the actress even considered leaving the
franchise altogether when being hermione
granger began interfering with her
education
she was constantly disrupted at school
and even had to deal with a stalker as a
teenager
however the producers worked around her
schedule and everything thank
goodness ended up working out my hair
was so associated with that role and
when i finished i just needed something
new
don't let the draco talk trend fool you
harry potter wasn't all fun and games
for tom felton no matter how much he
loved his character
he struggled later on with the fact that
starring in the franchise really
affected him growing up
basically he feels like his childhood
wasn't proper that's killed me
just killed me calm down it's just a
scratch and while he knows his childhood
brought him fame and money
he says the idea of money putting a
price on your childhood is ridiculous
because harry potter was all he knew for
years it continued to affect
him after he finished the franchise he
had to start auditioning for projects
again which was a huge
change in pace for him and made him
really nervous luckily
he's overcome his fears and has gone on
to land roles on hit shows like the
flash be very
hard to turn down any any offer to come
back to the world of hogwarts
maggie smith is much more like her
character professor mcgonagall than we
originally thought
especially when it comes to how blunt
she is place your
right hand on my waist while her years
on harry potter definitely brought her a
wider age range when it came to her fans
you're not gonna be too happy about how
she really feels about harry potter
she is of course grateful for the
opportunity she had in the
that films but she felt working on harry
potter was unsatisfying and said
i didn't really feel i was acting in
those things she even called wearing her
classic mcgonagall witch hat
exhausting if it makes you fans feel any
better she said the same thing about
working on downton abbey
i had a perfectly normal life until
downton
abbey we discovered just how much alan
rickman cared about harry potter and
severus snape
only after he had passed away back in
2018
notes and memorabilia he had collected
from all of his projects were found and
released
heartbreakingly his experience on the
last four harry potter movies wasn't his
favorite
he had conflicting ideas with director
david yates when it came to his
character
one note read inside snape's head it's
as if david yates has decided that this
is not important in the scheme of things
i.e teen audience appeal he thought his
character was being sacrificed to
satisfy the fans
you have your mother's eyes but
apparently his struggles go all the way
back to harry potter and the chamber of
secrets
they also discovered a note from
producer david heyman that said
thank you for making hp2 a success i
know
at times you're frustrated but please
know that you're an integral part of the
films
and you are brilliant rest in power alan
after all this time always
at this point you might be thinking did
everyone struggle with harry potter
the answer is basically yes even daniel
radcliffe himself
he had self-confidence problems that
were similar to emma watson's
it was his first major role and learning
to act on a big budget movie wasn't
exactly ideal and that never left him
but this is important this is about the
philosopher's stone
a lot of actors have self-doubt i live
under that the whole time
he's also spoken about how because of
his privileged life it was hard for
people to realize he was
also human if i am just feeling some
human emotion of sadness does that mean
i'm doing this wrong does that mean like
i'm not good at being
famous and that fame and spotlight led
to coping with alcohol
while filming he was struggling with
pretty bad substance abuse as a form of
escaping his life
forgetting about the fact that you're
being watched was to get very drunk
the fact that he still managed to bring
harry to us while struggling internally
the entire time
is something we'll never forget emma
thompson may not have had the biggest
role in the films
but regardless her time on set wasn't
the most joyous
there was really no big reason for her
dislike of filming on the harry potter
set
together we shall cast ourselves into
the future
she just wasn't a fan of filming for big
budget movies i must confess to you that
i have been with studios
i haven't enjoyed it she also apologized
for taking on small roles in blockbuster
movies just for the money
is she talking about professor trelawny
or
i'm not sure she's not mad for it i'm
afraid it didn't quite work out as i had
planned
if the other actors stories have broken
your hearts wait until you hear about
devin murray's time playing seamus
finnegan
he might have seemed extremely cheery on
screen despite his occasional potion
explosion mishap
but offset things were dark i had an
amazing life
i had a fantastic life but i also had to
give up on so much
devin was forced to move away from all
his family and friends in order to film
the movies
that sent him into a pretty depressive
state he's been extremely open about his
struggles now
and has admitted that although harry
potter was the best thing in his life
it turned into some of the worst times
of his life
i can see at the back of his head i'm
here across classrooms
donal gleason may have had his dad on
set with him during the filming
if you didn't know brendan gleason also
known as maddie moody is his father
but it wasn't all fun and games playing
the role of bill weasley came with a lot
of pressure for the actor
he struggled with bad anxiety when
filming and part of the reason was
because of the disastrous first day on
set he had
i was a harry potter fan but on my first
day on set on deathly hallows i had a
horrible day just a terrible day
supposedly the set was packed that day
and he just couldn't find his proper
english accent
it kept coming out australian all in all
donal had to learn to deal with pressure
and it looks like he did just that
matthew lewis started off as a shy 10
year old much like the rest of the cast
however his struggles with harry potter
started in the later films when he
entered his teens
after growing and thinning out matthew
feared that they would recast neville
instead they came up with the idea of
the false teeth and
bits of plastic to to stick my ears out
and
a fat suit he may not have lost his job
but it gave matthew horrible confidence
issues
there are girls around i've got this fat
suit on every day
no one knows i'm wearing this damn thing
they all just think i'm fat
it just goes to show you that the old
line money and fame aren't everything
is more than just a saying they may not
have had to deal with voldemort but the
harry potter actors were all
battling very real demons in their own
way what do you think about how the
actors felt during their time filming
harry potter
let us know in the comment section below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up
hit that subscribe button and we'll see
you later thanks for watching
you